der Reif warum man sich noch auf die WM
freuen darf
naja
es wird Fußball gespielt werden und ich
verstehe jeden der sagt pass auf das ist
mir alles zu viel das ist nicht mehr
mein Fußball das will ich nicht gucken
ist völlig in Ordnung nur ich bin kein
schlechter Mensch wenn ich mir Spiele
angucken werde wenn Sie mir wenn mir
irgendjemand und deswegen in meinem
Alter ist man dann eher doch glaube ich
pragmatischer wenn mir irgendjemand
garantieren kann das ist einem Arbeiter
einer Frau einem homosexuellen nach die
Welt dieser WM besser gehen oder danach
besser gehen wird wenn ich es
boykottiere bin ich sofort dabei mein
Ehrenwort bin ich sofort dabei
ich glaube allerdings dass jetzt über
Boykott zu reden das ist mir auch ein
bisschen zu wohlfalt zu weinen ich habe
das Gefühl Menschen sitzen hier im
warmen Sessel und sagen so jetzt wollen
wir mal sehen wie unsere Spieler da
reagiert aber ich habe ein Zeichen sehen
also was sie sollen Doppelpass spielen
und danach sofort ein Zeichen setzen die
sollen sich äußern wenn sie was zu sagen
haben und wenn sie informiert sind ich
hoffe dass der DFB und nach allem was
ich so gehört habe machen sie das das
sieht die Spieler darüber informieren
was sie dort erwartet nur dass wir uns
hier hinsetzen im Baumesse damit wir uns
wohler fühlen und sagen so macht das mal
da ich will wollen aber schon mal sehen
dass ihr da richtig mal Flagge zeigt das
ist mir ein bisschen zu billig aber wer
sagt denn das wer forderten
viele viele
Leute unterhalten die sagen sie werden
sich kein einziges Spiel sie werden die
Spiele gucken sie werden alternativ
Geschichten in Kneipen machen und dann
frage ich sag mal aber die deutschen
Spiele na gut die gucke ich mir an wir
sind das ist mir
das ist aber eine einfache Debatte also
viel wichtiger ist es doch jetzt darüber
zu reden welche Rolle die FIFA da
gespielt habt und dass sie eben einfach
die Spieler dazu zwingt wie auch schon
im Winter der das Internationale
Olympische Komitee die Athleten dazu
gezwungen hat unter solchen Bedingungen
ihr Bestes zu geben das ist einfach eine
Schweinerei und deswegen sollte nie
wieder so eine mega-sportveranstaltung
wie die WM an so ein Land vergeben
werden
die Frage von Herr ralf war ja sehr
spannend oder die Aussage wenn mir
jemand versichern kann dass ein
Menschenleben gerettet wird oder aus
einem Menschen besser geht in Katar dann
würde ich sofort das nicht schauen und
boykottieren aber das ist ja der Punkt
das heißt sie sagen auch ein Boykott
bringt jetzt nichts nein sehr viel zu
spät auch ja also wir hatten zum
Beispiel auch im Bundestag tatsächlich
eine Anhörung zu diesem Thema im
Frühjahr Sommer um den Dreh und da haben
wir Experten eingeladen die auch sehr
klar gesagt haben es ist naiv zu glauben
dass dadurch dem
digitalisierungsprozesse eintreten durch
wenn man das jetzt boykottiert oder wenn
man sich verspricht das durch so eine
wm-demokratieprozesse in Gang gestartet
werden nur richtig ist aber dass wir
gleichzeitig die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen ja ansprechen
und thematisieren und grundsätzlich wenn
Sportler auch Signale senden Zeichen
setzen finde ich das eine Idee wenn
beispielsweise die Spieler die
Regenbogenfahne tragen würden oder die
Flagge tragen würden warum nicht also
Sport und Fußball ist doch auch
Botschafter für Toleranz und
Völkerverständigung und grundsätzlich
finde ich das richtig und wenn es wenn
es Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt für die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und fünf
stärkeres Bewusstsein führt insbesondere
in der Öffentlichkeit dass das nicht in
Ordnung ist was da passiert und dadurch
auch der Druck aufgebaut wird auf das
Regime dann ist das richtig also die
europäischen Teilnehmer haben sich ja
gar nicht dass die Kapitäne eine eine
bunte nicht die regenbogenfreund die
reine Leere ist es nicht aber sie haben
sich geeinigt auf eine eine
Kapitänsbinde die ein Zeichen so
das sind so so ritualisierte Dinge da ja
es ist gut wir nehmen zur Kenntnis ist
gut das wird wird es nicht sein nur
nicht hin zu fahren und nichts mehr zu
tun jetzt wieder ich war mal hatte
Gelegenheit und drei Tage in Nordkorea
zu verbringen
und da stellt sich nicht die Frage bei
Nordkorea Boykott oder nicht zu und da
kommt niemand rein und die sind für sich
ich habe dort gesehen wie es Menschen
geht also deswegen ist mir jede
Möglichkeit irgendwo hinzufahren ja ich
würde nach al Journalist sofort nach
Katar fahren sofort nur wir machen es
von hier mit Bild TV ich würde sofort
fahren weil nicht in der Hoffnung dass
ich alles entdecke was es zu entdecken
gibt aber ein paar Dinge selber zu sehen
ich halte das für wichtig
vor Ort überhaupt freiberichten
können aber es wird Freiräume geben und
die geht es zu nutzen so gut es
und in den schönen Glitzer Gegenden das
werden wir sehen ob die katharis des
durchhalten jetzt haben schon die ersten
Journalisten die jetzt schon da sind
gesagt sie kommt kaum noch an die Arbeit
daran oder an die Frauen oder an
irgendwelche anderen weil die schon
eingeschüchtert sind so wenn auch ein
Überwachungsstaat absolut das heißt
jeder WhatsApp Post und so weiter wird
da von den Behörden auch mit gelesen bei
was wäre die Option nicht hinfahren als
Journalist umso wichtiger das
Journalisten hinfahren und wir haben ja
gerade am Anfang gesagt wenn Sie darüber
berichten dass sie nicht berichten
dürfen damit jeden Tag möchte ich das
Hören ja mal sehen wie der Druck auf die
Kataris wie sie da reagiert die sind
sehr sensibel in ihren Dingen und schlau
wenn die merken du pass auf dass das
geht gerade ganz schief diese WM wird
doch nicht wie er Infantino sagte die
beste aller Zeiten sondern hier geht was
richtig den Bach runter ist lassen sie
mir meine naive Sichtweise dass man
etwas schrittchenweise bewirken kann und
wie gesagt wenn es einem nur besser geht
danach hat es sich hat es schon Sinn
gemacht jetzt nicht zu Boykott
dass die Vergabe damals das war eine
große Chance zu einem solchen Zeitpunkt
zu sagen pass auf es gibt diese und
diese Kriterien und darunter springt
niemand wer da drunter springt auch nur
in einem Punkt ist raus aus der
Bewerbung das war die mit Abstand
schlechteste Bewerbung jeder sagt das
und der erzählt der der Platte also das
vorgelesen gezogen hat der war ja selber
entsetzt
so mal davon abgesehen ob er nicht
vorher schon ich würde sagen wir machen
hier heute schon mal den gefangen denn
es ist wichtig wie Herr reif sagt dass
man berichten muss und reden muss
darüber was in Katar